what is the greatest song of all time
oh objectively speaking the greatest
song of all time
i i suppose that could change moment to
moment day to day
but if you were forced to answer for
this particular moment in your life
that's something that pops to mind
this could be both philosophically this
could be technically as a musician like
what you enjoy maybe lyrics like for me
it's lyrics is very important so
absolutely i would probably it would be
my choice would be lyrics based i don't
want to answer in terms of just
technical
uh you know technical prowess i think
technical prowess is impressive right
it's just like
it's impressive what can be done i
wouldn't place that into the category of
the greatest music ever written
some the classical music uh
that's that's written is undeniably
beautiful but i don't want to
consider that category of music
either uh just because you know so if i
if i
limit uh the scope of this
philosophical discussion uh to
you know the kind of music that i listen
to you know probably what's my age again
by blink 182. it's just you know it's a
solid one
it's got you know
said nobody ever that's a good song
i don't know if you're joking about it i
i am
[Laughter]
no i mean it would probably you know
songwriting-wise i think the beatles
came pretty close to
the influential to you i was like the
beatles yeah
love the beatles i love the beatles uh
let it be
yesterday yeah like straw i think
strawberry feels forever is
is one you know what what one of my
favorite beetle songs is
it's uh you know in my life right
that's not it's it's hard to imagine how
whatever
24 year old wrote that it is one of the
most
uh introspective pieces of music ever
you know i'm a huge pink floyd fan
and so i think you know if you were to
you can sort of look at the entire dark
side of the moon album
and as you know getting pretty close up
there to the pinnacle of what
you know can be created so you know
time's a great song
yeah it's a great song just the entirety
of
just the instruments the lyrics the the
the feeling created by a song
like pink floyd can create
feelings the entire experience i mean
you have that with the wall
of just uh transporting you into another
place
songs don't not many songs could do that
as as
as well uh not many artists can do that
as well as pink floyd did
there are a lot of bands that you can
kind of say oh yeah
like if you take blink 182 right if you
have
no idea like if you are listening to
sort of that type of pop punk for the
first time
it's difficult to differentiate between
blink 182 and like sum 41
and the thousand of other like lesser
known
bands that all sounded the hell they all
had that sparkling production
uh feel they all kind of sounded the
same
uh right when with pink floyd it's hard
to find another band that you're like
well is this one pink floor or like you
know
yeah when you're listening to that what
you're listening to
the uniqueness that that's fascinating
you know in the calculation
of the greatest song in the greatest
band of all time
you could probably you probably actually
quantify this like scientifically
it's like how unique uh if you play
different songs how well are people
able to recognize whether it's this band
or not and that you know that's
probably a huge component to greatness
like if the world would miss it if it
was gone
yes yes so but there's also the human
story things like i would say output
johnny cash's cover of hurt as one of
the greatest songs of all time
and that has less to do with the song
but your interaction with it
interaction with it but also the human
the full story of the human
so like it's not just if i just heard
the song it'd be like okay
that but if it it's the full story of it
also the video component for that
particular song
so like that you can't discount the full
experience of it absolutely
you know i have no confusion about not
about being you know anywhere uh
you know in in that league but i just
like i
sometimes think about you know music
that is being
uh produced today feels
oftentimes feels like like kind of
clothes like clothes that you buy
at like h m and you wear three times
before they rip and you throw away so
like so much of it
is it's not bad it's just kind of
forgettable
right like the fact that we're talking
about pink floyd
in 2021 is in itself an interesting
uh question why are we talking about
pink floyd and it's there's something
unforgettable about them
and unforgettable about the the art that
they created
that could be the markets that like so
spotify has created this kind of
market where the the incentives for
creating music
that last is much lower because there's
so much more music
right you just want something that
shines bright for a short amount of time
makes a lot of money and moves on and i
mean the same thing you see with the
news and all those kinds of things we're
just living in a
shorter and shorter shorter like uh time
scale in terms of our attention spans
and that um nevertheless when we look at
the long arc of history of music perhaps
there will be some songs from today
that will last as much as pink floyd
we're just unable to see it
yeah just the collected works of
nickelback
exactly you know you never know you
never know justin bieber
it could have yeah it could be a
contender i've recently started
listening to justin bieber just
understand what people are talking about
and
you know i'll just keep my comments to
myself on that one it's too good to
explain
in the words capture
the greatness that is the biebs
you